the first criminal trial from the
january 6th that's sold on the capitol
begins this morning a texas man accused
of carrying a gun during the riot is the
first defendant to face a jury scott
mcfarlane is outside the courthouse in
washington to show us how this trial
could have wide-ranging implications
scott good morning hey nate good morning
to you for the first time the u.s
justice department is showing its hand
in a january six case setting the tone
for potentially hundreds more cases to
come
guy refit of the dallas area is accused
of charging at police while having that
gun on his waistband he's facing charges
of unlawful transport of a firearm and
furtherance of civil disorder and
obstructing the work of the u.s congress
he's also accused of being a member of
this three three percenters militia
group another member of that group is on
the prosecutor's witness list so to our
record son and daughter whom he's
accused of threatening if they turned
him into the fbi
referet has been jailed pending trial in
this case he's pleaded not guilty faces
decades behind bars if convicted
he tried to get this trial moved from
this washington d.c courthouse to his
home state of texas arguing the media
coverage was going to bias the jury that
request
was denied of the nearly 750 federal
defendants in the capitol riot about a
third of them have pleaded guilty but
gail the other two thirds
closely watch what happens here
beginning this morning
we're all going to be watching this
thank you very much scott